a lot of us are getting into self-care
and you have really been taking it to a
high level like with the beard you're
doing things with your beard you've
never done before I just I never used I
never had enough hair on my face I mean
if you look at this sad-ass Cat Stevens
happening here it's this is the goatee
that knows who it is and these guys
being like what are we doing out here so
yeah I've been I've been like
conditioning the beard and just having a
softer facial expression dition errs for
beards I didn't know that and and it is
it it's not here's where I made the
mistake of saying I just used my regular
conditioner on the beard and I said it
in a public place
does it have like a nice sandalwood odor
does it smell like a Yankee Candle - by
special I guess that's the next step if
I'm going to be a beard bin if I'm going
full offerman yeah I can't do a full
offer minute
no only Offerman can do I've seen
Offerman shave in the morning and then
I've had dinner with him that night and
he's got a full giant grizzly bear yeah
there you go
because some people might think oh the
rest of us are doing nothing but
lin-manuel Miranda he's you know writing
a full-on opera about my beard and
putting lotion on my feet and like
wrapping them up like a marinade
putting your putting lotion on your feet
I am
that's my new Jade I know Alyssa I'm not
a Philistine like I put on like a lotion
shower I put on lotion like a human
person I don't I'm completely honest
with you I don't lotion I've never
lotion I have the driest skin in the
world I have the hands of a t-rex yeah
well no my feet were really like kind of
cracked
I've just been running around barefoot
in the house and then my wife said put
like too much lotion on your feet put
socks on like right away and it's like
just like exactly that face lean into
that and then just like just squish it
doesn't it squish around when you're
walking yeah
lean into the crevasse just like go swim
down into it hey strangers feet at the
end of the day coming oh I see then
suddenly they I have I have that that
feeling that that my feet are some other
person's feet which might be very erotic
for myself yes and where my
[Laughter]